give us the importance to to
um recognize the act of a uh you know a
female that moves in a uh promiscuous uh
manner um and what would you advise the
uh the youth to look out for when
they're dealing with a promiscuous woman
because you know a lot of times dudes
that might have that um scarcity mindset
might link out with a female that young
man that belongs to the streets so um
it'll be uh dope for you to give us a
breakdown on that and I mean
yeah so female promiscuity is a recent
phenomenon openly anyway
um I think women have been
somewhat promiscuous in the past anyway
because in many cases they're forced to
like if they pair bonded with a guy and
he goes off Hunting the Sabretooth tiger
and he died she'd have to pair bond to
another guy so women are adapt to mate
switch from guy to guy a lot of people
in the man of swamp call it like monkey
branching you know for example because
women can move very quickly from dudes
but um a woman that has been with a
bunch of guys is a extremely bad choice
for a long-term mate Choice especially
if you're looking for something like a
mother for your kids you know for
example there's been lots of studies
done on this they're all factual people
get pissed off at it all the time it
doesn't matter you know getting mad at
the facts doesn't change the fact that
they're facts if you have a problem with
the facts the problem is not with the
foxes with you basically but they all
reveal the exact same uh
end game which is a woman that's been
with more guys has a harder time
sticking to a guy in a long-term
relationship so for example
and by the way another part of that
equation is the younger they are when
they lose their virginity again the less
likely they are to form a healthy pair
bond to a guy so if you take two women
you take a woman that's 14 and she loses
her virginity and has been with 100 guys
by the time she's 30 and you know gets
right with God and wants to settle down
and have family and stuff like that and
you take another woman that was maybe 23
and was with one guy in a long-term
relationship for seven years you meet
her again at 30 you're dating these two
women you know simultaneously a lot of
guys will just Overlook her promiscuous
past like the woman that's been with 100
guys they'll just say ah you know she's
gotten right with God she's a good
person she says she wants a family she's
serious but women are interested in a
men's future men need to be interested
in women's past the woman with the big
Notch count
sucks
statistically speaking at staying in a
healthy monogamous pair-bonded
relationship with the men they leave
marriages women leave marriages eight
times out of ten so whenever there's a
divorce filed through the courts it's
usually women filing it not men and the
vast majority of women that are doing it
are women with larger Notch counts right
the fact of life it's an unfortunate you
know reality but promiscuity doesn't
affect men the same way that it affects
women so you know she's been with a
bunch of guys so what's the difference
if your guy number 101 and things aren't
going her way in the marriage maybe
you're not providing maybe you're not
paying for stuff maybe you're not
agreeing to everything that she wants
what's going to stop her from bouncing
to guy number 102. if she's already done
it a hundred times right and and if
you've got kids with their family law is
going to cover her ass and protect her
to make sure that she's got full access
to the kids or or strong access to the
kids and money flows from the father to
the mother there's really no benefit
whatsoever to pair bonding with women
over a long-term basis they might make
good uh F buddies you know Friends with
Benefits uh you know like fun girls but
you certainly don't want to give them
the key to your house or you know put a
ring on their finger or anything like
that
right and um sometimes guys they have a
hard time to discern whether you know
she's
um uh marriage material or they might
you know just fall for the okie dokie
and wife up a smut that belongs to the
street now
um my next question for you is do you
think like the laws
um get these females conditioned to
um get a scapegoat with these uh
marriages and um you know take it due to
the cleaners like um you think the law
kind of like perpetuate that um
somewhat negative behavior kind of like
a a negative reinforcement I mean a
positive reinforcement yeah that's one
of the problems that I talked about in
family law in my book as well um you're
gonna have to read the um book to get
the full details but to sort of
summarize an area of the book there's a
woman that um
was a uh uh a married woman and uh she
had a couple kids
and if you know as women do when they're
sitting around at work on their lunch
break they uh talk and she was talking
to a friend of hers that was a single
mom does the exact same job so let's say
their customer service reps you know for
example they make the exact same money
and they were comparing what their
take-home income was monthly the married
woman with the kids and then the single
mom with the kids that was also divorced
and even though they did the exact same
job the government the way that it
structures family law makes sure that
the single mom gets paid more money
monthly take home income she gets a
higher take-home income than the married
woman and the point that the married
woman made it in these comments and I've
got it word for word so you can actually
re read the exact quotes in the books
but the point that she made was that
there's no incentive for me to stay
married to my husband there's incentives
in law and employment law so that women
who leave their husbands actually can
have a higher take-home income and they
don't have to put up with this [__]
either right you know because the money
has to flow to them but they don't
necessarily have to put up with his [__]
you know as they like to say sort of
thing so that kind of exemplifies how
Society is structured today and most
people don't understand that like when I
say unplug you know from the lies that's
one of the thousands of lies that I'm
talking about that a lot of people
refuse to accept because they think
they've been told their entire life just
do the right thing be a man you know
wipe her up have a family you know have
babies with her and stuff like that but
one of the things that you start to
realize when you unplug for the Matrix
is they tell men and women very
different things they tell men you do
what's right but they tell women you do
what's right for you girl
right so there's a big difference there
um now what you know what's the um blue
pill
do you know
with the blue pill thing right like
do you think
like what's the solution to help guys
that's indoctrinated with this uh
um blue pill mindset like do you think
there's a solution or is this one of
those things where you gotta um
you know learn through life experience
because sometimes sometimes when you
give them the cheat code you know they
they might turn around and get mad at
you for giving them that good advice and
I mean yeah and they usually do like
most plugged in betas will get pissed
off at you they'll call you names
they'll say that you're a massage and
this'll ask you questions like who hurts
you and stuff like that you know women
especially you you know use that line
but look it like my advice to guys is
don't try to unplug people that don't
want it right like the teacher will
appear when the student is ready as the
old saying goes so what usually
happens is some chaos happens in some
guy's life they get heartbroken they you
know their girlfriend cheats on them go
and [__] some guys you know sort of
thing and then they start looking for
answers on the internet maybe they find
my YouTube video maybe they find you
know a link to something posted in some
discussion forum or you know something
like that and then that's when they
start to read and dive deep into the
rabbit hole and then they start to
realize yeah okay now this kind of adds
up and makes sense now I understand why
she did what she did and why women make
these choices and
um you know so on and so forth because
there's so many different
tunnels and past it you go down when you
start to discover this new information
that helps you level up in life and what
a lot of guys like to do is they go and
find that information because of the
chaos they had in life and they go and
sit down with their buddies and they're
like dude you got to hear about this
hypergamy thing or you got to understand
that women don't care about your
struggles they hang out at the finish
line and they [__] the winners and they
start using these sound bites right
right and most of these guys are like
they're not ready for it you know it's
like they aren't even close to being
ready for it because they have an
experience that experience the chaos
that the guy that was sitting there one
night thinking about putting a noose
around his neck and ending his life they
never get to that part of like absolute
trauma and unfortunately it seems like
that's what guys have to get close to is
they have to feel that you know the
sleepless nights they're they've got
that gut wrench and pain where they
can't eat you know or like whatever it
happens to be because of that trauma in
their life and it usually comes because
of relationships with women but when you
start to
take the blinders off you ever see those
horses you know walking in the park with
the blinders on and they'll only see
straight well that's how most guys start
you know they they have the blinders on
it like okay now I now I think I
understand the true nature of women you
know I've unplugged they've taken the
red pill whatever it is you want to call
it and then they start to expand that
they're like oh [__] they lied to me
about a whole bunch of stuff they lied
to me about
um medical procedures they lied to me
about the pandemic they lied to me about
education they lied to me about degrees
it's like you start to see that there's
a lot of lies that are perpetuated in
society to try to control you to keep
you under the thumb right
okay okay also so you kind of like okay
I go well beyond just checks like most
of the guys out there focus on getting
the girls right and it's like dude you
know like when you take the blinders off
and you start to see the rest of the
world around that it's not just women in
relationships that you've been lied
about you've been lied about how to make
money you've been lied about how to
create wealth you've been lied about
about medical procedures and the health
you know conditions and stuff like that
right right I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out